okay welcome Oh daddy just wants to eat
you up oh my god sausage you guys must
be so excited actually we got pepperoni
pepperoni is great to his come on in get
in here
I'm not normally a pizza person but this
pizza is so awesome I mean you could
tell by looking at it is gonna have a
perfect crust somebody's getting a great
yelp review oh no not everything is fine
everything is okay
yeah stringy is natural you know all
fresh pizzas are say cheese okay listen
don't get me wrong
hurry I'm really glad we got the pizza
it's just I'm not sure if I'm ready to
take care of it I mean I had a pretty
big breakfast look at this guy he's a
natural huh
maybe maybe you guys would be ordering
your own pizza soon I don't even know if
we can afford a pizza you know because
not just that it's the napkins the soda
toppings no topics you got save for the
future
I mean you're gonna need Tupperware oh
that's right you got it you got it you
got it you got it okay
okay so where's Shirley you have a
meeting tonight Shirley Oh
uh surely you can't have pizza it's
tragic
Poli wake up wake up the refrigerator
just made a noise can you go check on
the pizza maybe it's your turn